why do so many like ugly guys have such  a high body count if that's the case but  it's not true is it because they have  money it might be money no they're not  actually ugly that's the thing you you  think they're ugly because women find 80  of men unattractive but it's the same  move like ugly girls as well like how  how I come it's so easy for them to get  the guy what's the 10. well yeah it  depends there's a couple dynamics that I  see if the guys attend like usually she  has other qualities  um  oh is he dating her sleeping with her no  just sleeping together oh well guys will  sleep with anything  guys look guys will sleep with girls  they would never be seen in public with  ever yeah and you see people cheat with  uglier girls like they might have a bang  anymore why does that happen yeah yeah  you got to worry about the ugly girls  too you gotta work oh that's your baby  mama